When the aliens first invaded, they nearly destroyed us.
They will be back.
There's greatness in you, Ender.
The world needs you.
You are bred for this.
You see things in a way we can't.
You alone can understand the enemy.
You will be the one to save mankind.
Unless we act now, Earth will be annihilated.
We're out of time.
He's not ready.
You're never ready.
You'll know when you're ready enough.
Track them from below the ice.
Shoot straight.
Stay calm.
Here we go.
Fire!
I've never seen anyone do that.
They should tell him the truth.
Why?
When it's over, what would be left of the boy?
What does it matter if there's nothing left at all?
If you don't try then we will all be lost.
I'll do everything I can to win this war.
If you succeed, you will be remembered as a hero.
He's abandoning his entire fleet.
He's in command, there's no stopping him now.
In three, two, one!
Now!